[Music]
after all she's been through she's
trying to make up for what happened to
her you mean how Wes for brainwashed her
and made her come after us no one's
blaming Jill for that
no one
what's up Jill
Dr and Taylor yes we need him in custody
ASAP I checked the DNA we got from a
bite wound on an orca carcass it had a
strain of t-virus in it you're kidding I
found the connection between the folks
that were infected they all visited
Alcatraz recently
well Dr Taylor
it's time we debuted our
creation
they turn fast and without being bitten
I'm Rebecca what do you want me to tell
them someone accessed the dod server
they managed to steal data on Leon Jill
Chris and Claire you think this might
have something to do with the operon now
most likely
I'm going to use my virus to clean this
light
Dylan suckers you're nothing more than
Pawns
foreign
[Music]
let's do it all of us
definitely going on vacation after this
[Music]